- It's an interesting thing,
how we navigate with
technology now, like in our,
in the present and then how it exactly.
And it's interesting how it
is in the film and it's a nice
little metaphor. It points.
And I don't know if that was on purpose,
but it's like about how good
can come from it and also bad.
And so are, y'all like really?
Are you mindful? Like you have kids,
are you mindful about the
technology with like your kids and
stuff? Yeah.
- Yeah, totally.
I think it's the interesting
question to ask right now is
like, how do we stay human in it?
Right. Yeah.
And that's what I'm kind of
interested in exploring for
myself and for my kids,
because we didn't have
all this technology.
We don't really know yet what
it's going to be like. Right.
Okay.
- I had like Oregon trail,
like on the computer,
like I am old.
- I didn't have that.
We had the phone with like the long cord
- Oh the Roseanne at cord. Yeah.
That too. Yeah.
Yeah. From the Roseanne show, anybody no?
- Wasn't it back then too like
get off the phone, you know
like you're like on the
phone for six hours.
- Yeah I know.
- You were on the phone
for six hours? With who?
- At least four.
- Oh my God. I wasn't.
- Really, I loved it.
It was so fun.
- Hanging off the bed upside down.
- Oh my God, I want to see
you as a teenager right now.